el jefe de la oposición ha insistido una
vez más que johnson debe irse del poder
porque no es apto para hacer primer
ministro es de interés nacional que dé
un paso al costado porque el país
requiere un líder que pueda liderar y
todos los desafíos masivos que enfrenta
el país no solamente para atender la
pandemia del coi 19 sino también los
otros ha dicho decir que esta arma
además que boris johnson se ha
contradecido dando explicaciones sobre
estas fiestas por ahora a boris johnson
tiene el apoyo de su partido pero no se
sabe hasta cuándo ya figuras senior
veteranas del partido conservador han
empezado a tomar distancia porque creen
que el tiempo de johnson en el gobierno
está terminado uno de los diputados como
partidarios robert girl ha dicho que
johnson es un hombre políticamente
muerto caminando pero el partido
conservador está a la espera de una
investigación que establecerá si johnson
rompió o no las reglas las leyes del
confinamiento con estas fiestas si no
los convence entonces podríamos ver muy
probablemente una consulta para
preguntarles si johnson debe seguir o no
como primer ministro